on the Nobel Prize talks podcast each
individual is a powerhouse Mohamed
Younis we do recognize in our society we
left them to do work many L work this
work that were we forgot this is a
powerhouse in to this in young people
and more powerful powerhouse than
yesterday's one in conversation with me
Adam Smith because these young people
have lots of access to information and
communication the community of it makes
them more powerful and then if they put
it their attention in solving problems
all these problems will disappear before
they come to the middle age of their
life 50 year old meaning another 25
years they can create a completely new
world a world where not a single person
will be per person a word heart not a
single person would be unemployed person
have a listen to the podcast on ever
priced at all iTunes and on Android
devices